good morning John you remember a couple
months ago when I made a video
specifically to blow your mind it was
about the Hubble ultra-deep field
experiment well this video is kind of a
continuation of that video if you
haven't seen that video go and watch it
now so there are between 100 billion and
400 billion stars in our galaxy so a
while back a very well-respected
scientist named Enrico Fermi was talking
with some of his very well-respected
scientists buddies now talking about
humanity and civilization and the giant
nosov the universe and Enrico Fermi
called out where are they because that's
kind of the question if there are 400
billion stars in our galaxy chances are
a lot of them have planets and a lot of
those planets could support life and a
lot of those planets that can support
life have life and a lot of that life
that has been supported has evolved into
an advanced civilization and if that's
the case based on the way that humanity
has done things and if interstellar
travel is possible then one would assume
that we would continue growing
exponentially into we had colonized the
entire galaxy and so if that is the case
where are they and even if they don't
expand like our civilization has and
even if interstellar travel isn't
possible we should at least be able to
hear them we should at least have some
evidence that they exist our
civilization has been broadcasting ultra
high-frequency broadband signals into
the galaxy that can be detected tens of
thousands of light-years away so we
assume that other civilizations have
likewise also been doing it and if they
have been then we should be able to
detect that as distinctly artificial non
natural phenomenon that we can then say
hey look aliens have television too and
they watch it all the time and they're
out there but we haven't been able to do
that as far as we can tell
aliens either aren't out there or
they're not watching TV that was a
simplification examining this it's
called the Fermi paradox why we don't
hear them if there should be so many of
them helps me think a lot more about
humanity and our civilization then it
helps me think about alien civilizations
it is possible and this constantly
worries me that advanced civilization
tends to destroy itself and this could
of course happen in any ways it could
happen in the familiar ways where we
think about atomic winter and all of us
dying working out
more peculiar ways like big natural
events advanced civilizations for some
reason losing interest in procreation
which I kind of understand or maybe the
civilizations changed into something
that we can't quite understand maybe
they download their consciousnesses into
giant planet wide computers that need no
materials only the power provided by the
Sun and they sit there looking like a
ball of rock transmitting no signals for
us to decipher but there are other
options too maybe they're hiding all you
people who love Star Trek the way that I
do you know about the prime directive
the prime directive it says don't mess
with non spacefaring civilizations you
could totally screw them up or maybe the
aliens have us locked in a little zoo
and they're watching us and doing little
scientific experiments and chuckling
when we try and kill each other over
whose religion is more accurate or maybe
you know we aren't as advanced as we
think we are for barely a hundred years
we've been broadcasting radium that
might seem like a long time but friends
it is not if the nearest civilization
that could detect our signals is fifty
thousand light-years away then our radio
signals won't be getting there for
another forty nine thousand nine hundred
years the first civilization to hear our
radio signals spilling out into space
might not even exist yet and by the time
they hear those signals we might not
exist anymore but we do know of one
advanced civilization at least it might
be unique or it might be one of millions
but there's only one that we can even
observe and so we have to observe it
carefully and most importantly protect
it as much as we can from its greatest
enemy which is of course itself question
do you nerdfighteria is do you think
there's my fount there somewhere in the
galaxy and do you think we'll never see
anything of it and if we do will they
kill us or will they be friendly John
I'll see you on Friday